you had the floyd mary weather and um
uh po uh
logan paul went at it and it really it
kind of had a um
i mean logan paul comes in he came in
hella german on that fight when you're
looking at him
real swedish very viking very like damn
this fell owns an axe type of look
you know and uh
i don't know you know i don't know if i
like watching do i want to see
millionaires fight each other i wa i
want the underdog in there
i feel like
and i guess you know floyd has accusings
of wife of uh
you know you know he's be fifty fifty
he's fifty and oh seven of his wins came
against ex-wives
allegedly and so
you know maybe that's what you want to
see i don't know i was just wondering
what made me want to
you know i was on the airplane i i
there's no streaming on there
so you have to just guess what's
happening which is you know
it's like the old days really
you know you used to be like what
happened somebody tell you they
described it
dude it was lightning then the guy and
then
no he couldn't even i don't know man
it's unbelievable
it's on my way by ball
but then it's you know it just gets
different you know and now it's like
there's just
so much you get so many of the recaps
and stuff but i'm on this plane
i'm trying to get the thing to uh stream
it wouldn't
but about every 55 seconds it would give
me a um
glimpse just a jpeg just a
bam and uh
yeah and so i you know i had no idea
what was happening
it looked kind of like a couple of
square dancers look a couple of young
men
that had met somewhere and was doing
drugs and you know
probably at a men's club a nightclub but
yeah i tried to watch on the airplane i
couldn't do it
i could not get that thing to uh to load
up in the function
um and so i just got a glimpse every now
and then
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another
and you can watch this one you can watch
this one different options different
choices
some guy just brings you one option not
this guy
two options watch one this one or this
one